so yeah so my name is John mount and
this is dr. Nina zoom al and we're gonna
be presenting some some of our work on
dealing with messy data which it's kind
of a fun funny thing to say is like is
there any kind of data other than messy
so you don't really need that word so
who are we well scientists that normally
work with our and we have with us the
fresh new version of practical data
science with our second edition which
amazon just admitted exists today so
they they were ghosting us up till now
so today's a good day for us if you
don't exist for amazon you don't exist
at all so for years we've been using
this package in our and we've built a
new python version that is pythonic it's
not an r package in python it's an
actual python package so what we're
gonna discuss with you is first the
problem why do you have to prepare data
at all why can't you just use data as it
comes into your system on your ingest
system and then we'll show modeling with
and without v treat and obviously we're
gonna show that it's very bad not to use
v treat that we're huge fans of our own
package and then we'll describe the
package and we'll show some of the
technology that makes it actually work
because it turns out when you once you
touch the data everything's your fault
and you have actually a really great
opportunity to introduce overfitting and
nested model bias if you don't do
something very clever which nina will
describe and then we'll get to some
references so why do we prepare data
well basically often the data is quite
dirty
it'll have missing values strange
categorical variables variables string
variables that new strings occur during
application that you didn't see during
training you know once you touch real
world data it'll do anything to hurt you
the also thing is especially in psych it
or the Python psych it world most of the
machine learning algorithms expect a
pure numeric data frame that they don't
want any categorical or string valued
variables left around and we want to get
into that format in a systematic way so
again you can't automate data science
that you have to actually care about and
look at your data we're trying to
automate the simple steps so you have
more time for important domain specific
interventions so again as I said typical
data problems missing values categorical
variables those are variables whose
values or strings are interpreted as
strings and categorical variables with
very many levels such as zip code which
has 70,000 possible levels and that's
very statistically inefficient to deal
with those directly so as an example
dataset we're just gonna kick something
nobody cares about it's the kdd cup 2009
dataset and it was to predict churn or
account cancellation in a credit card
account and the data was truly horrific
just a data summary it was 230 columns
with no data dictionary so they never
said when any of the columns were they
all had cryptographic names there were
lots of variables
50,000 instances which is not a lot in
our day and age it had both numeric and
categorical variables
most of them were completely infested
with missing values and many of the
categorical variables were high
cardinality which means they took on a
lot of cryptic different values and
again no data dictionary no way to roll
up or join into anything useful and it
was basically it was an unbalanced task
also just as churn is the cancellation
of an account and around 7 percent of
the people in the observation window did
this this is what happens if you throw
the data @xg boost as is and basically
in red we have the exception that was
raised and that extra boost said that
you know some of the variables were of
types I am unwilling to do deal with and
again that's not a mathematical issue
you can do tree based methods and
boosting on categorical variables but
with this type of API especially this is
not scikit-learn but with scikit-learn
you're not allowed to have non numeric
columns so you need to prep the data now
even if you fixed this you would then
run into your next problem that you
still have missing values then you'd run
into your next problem that even though
you've Rhian coded some of the
categorical variables you've blown up
your data set into hundreds of thousands
of columns when we only had 50,000 rows
so and then you get the rare levels and
novel levels which are statistically
even if you have enough data processing
memory to deal with them they're
statistically Poisson anyway
so grab-bag solution yeah scikit-learn
one hot encoder plus the simple and
pewter Plus maybe Karis layer you're
embedding to eliminate no so why would
we not do that lots of steps to manage
may not be statistically efficient and
possibly subject to this sort of over
fit bias that a lot of people have been
considered very deeply though the
stacking community has thought about
this quite deeply so basically there's
got to be a better way and in our
prejudiced mind that better way is our
own package V treat it's easy to use it
has known good performance and it has
sizable documentation see basically you
can add this to your methods section and
you're quite far along in your
documentation here is V treat working on
the kdd 2009 dataset I'm sorry we will
put up all these slides on the wind
vector blog so all you need to do is
search for wind vector blog and we'll
have the entire deck up with all URLs
should have said that earlier so
basically all we need to do is call fit
transform fit underbar transform that's
it we try to do a sidekick Learn
pipeline style interface call fit
underbar transform not fit and transform
but always the underbar form and what
that gave us was an a you see on held
out our test data of 0.73 which is
abysmal but for this problem in the
ballpark of the winning solutions they
were in around 0.7 for 2.6 after many
days of effort so this gives you a
fire-and-forget that we used v tree with
no hyper parameter tuning we used XG
boost with no hyper parameter tuning and
in ten minutes we're in the ballpark of
winning which again life isn't the
Kaggle contest so in the ballpark is
business good so there's the results
sorry I spoke ahead in my slides and
again here's the reference to the
contest all these links are in the
slides which we will share on the wind
vector blog so the V treat goal is to be
ready faithful and reliable so basically
the data needs to be converted into a
ready to use data format which means all
numeric columns not an obscene number of
columns and the data is not encrypted
you haven't done something completely
strange the machine learning algorithm
has to work hard to overcome that the
information is there but at the surface
level by faithful we mean most of
information in the original data set is
still there we can't preserve
all of it for the high cardinality
categorical variables but we're gonna
preserve a lot of it and we're gonna
preserve all the common information and
by reliable we mean it doesn't introduce
additional problems on its own in
particular the nested model or stacked
model bias that it has a very
sophisticated cross validation method to
make sure we don't run into that so the
main benefit of V treat is it's built on
top of pandas so it reasons in terms of
column names which is again given our
our background we like column names and
what it gives you also which using one
hot encoder alone dozen is a concordance
between the original variable names and
the new variable names and again the
first three columns of this score frame
which is part of the V treats side
effects is what's really interesting the
original variable says I was a variable
named X I produced two variables one
called X one called X is bad I'm reading
off the first two rows the X is bad is a
missing indicator and the X is a clean
copy so the third column says what was
the treatment strategy that built these
derived variables and this lets you then
attribute new variables to old variables
so with that I'm gonna switch over to
what does V treat do okay thanks John
now that John has given you kind of a
quick overview and introduction to what
you might want to be interested in V
treat I'm gonna go into a little bit
more detail about how it actually works
on the data so the first thing that V
treat does is that it repairs numerical
variables that have missing values or
other problematical variables like not
Oh numbers replaces those problematical
variables with more benign stand-ins by
default the observed mean of that
variable but it can be other values as
well like the median or the min of the
Max or even a constant in addition to
replacing problematical variables B
treat also adds an additional variable
an indicator variable that you saw you
John pointed it out it's called the is
bad variable and that marks where these
problematical variables were replaced
adding this extra column makes this
particular transform basically
invertible which means that we are
preserving as much of the data in the
original variable as was there for use
by the downstream modeling algorithms
and if any of you were at the Auto
impute talk yesterday you can also think
of this particular transform as being a
compromise between treating random
missing variables as missing at random
and missing systematically often you
don't know why you have missing this in
your data whether it's random or
systematic and so Petri just kind of
splits the difference and treats it like
it's both again for downstream modeling
algorithms to kind of sort out and
figure out what's going on and in fact
we find in practice that these is that
in missingness indicators are sometimes
even more useful than the original
variable itself and the reason that that
might be is that often the data that
you're collecting in order to do your
job comes to you from a variety of
different processes and sometimes the
difference in these process manifests
itself in missingness in some of the
data and that's kind of an implicit kind
of information that's in the data and by
adding an explicit indicator variable
you've made that data explicit and
therefore more accessible to downstream
modeling algorithms so consequently
these is bad indicators can be sometimes
the most informative variables in your
data the second thing that Vitry does is
to encode categorical levels as
indicators this is pretty straight
forward
essentially what Vitry does is similar
to calling psych it learns one hot
encoder with the parameters drop equals
none and handle unknown equals ignore
for those of you who are not familiar
with handle unknown equals ignore it
allows the one hot encoder to gracefully
handle novel levels so for example if
you have a data set of customer data and
one of the features that you want to use
is the state of residence and let's say
that the training data has only
customers from four states California
Nevada Oregon Washington the water had
one hot encoder envy treat will
basically turn those four states into
four indicator variables and those are
the only states that the model when you
train a model on that data that the
model will know about
so you build a model you want to apply
it to new set of customers and bingo
some of these customers come from
Wyoming which the model has never seen
now if you had built this model in our
without feet rate and remember Vitry was
originally in our package the our model
would crash on saying customers from
Wyoming and if you build it in Python
without using the proper unknown handler
so if you use the wrong parameters for
one hunting coder the model will also
crash if you use the right parameters or
if you use via trait what happens is
that novel levels are treated as
basically no level they're encoded as
all zeros with the indicator variable
this allows the model to continue to
process customers from Wyoming in South
Dakota and any place that's not seen
without crashing which is a good thing
the primary difference between what one
hot encoder does and what Vitry does is
that V treat does not by default dummy
encode all of the observed levels of a
variable of a categorical variable
it only encodes the most frequent ones
and the reason it only encodes the most
frequent ones is because V treat is
trying to explicitly manage dummy
variable blow-up from high cardinality
categorical variables and by a high
cardinality variable categorical
variable I mean a categorical variable
that has you know several hundred or
maybe even thousands of possible levels
zip code is the class of example John
brought it up there's something like he
said seven
I forget what number he said but what I
looked it up there's something like
42,000 ZIP codes in the United States
almost three thousand them in California
alone so let's imagine that you are
trying to build a model to predict home
sale price for houses in California and
what are the features that you want to
use is the zip code of the house so even
if you're just looking at California and
not the rest of the country just from
this one feature zip code you can
potentially have almost 3,000 variables
and that's before even considering any
of the other variables that you're
looking at
having too many variables in your data
is a problem for a couple of reasons one
is that too many variables can be a
computational problem for a lot of
machine learning algorithms and more
significantly if you have too many
variables with respect to the number of
rows that you have you have an overly
wide data set then you're going to have
an under constrained problem if you're
trying to use a more complex machine
learning algorithm which usually we are
these days and the easiest way to unto
accidentally have an overly wide data
set is to have a couple of variables
that are categorical variables that are
very high cardinality or even to just
have a lot of moderately sized
categorical variables that together add
up to a lot of indicator variables so
you want to manage that vtrene manages
it one of two two different ways one is
as I mentioned it only dummy encodes the
most frequent levels of the categorical
variables so basically it only in dummy
codes levels that occur more frequently
than some user-defined thresholds say
levels that only occur more than in more
than 2% or one fiftieth of the data and
the reason you want to do that is that
limits the number of dummy variables
that are created per categorical
variables so if we set the threshold to
2% and then we go do the V treat dummy
encoding of zip code what we will get
remember 2% is 1 over 50 so what we will
get is at most indicator variables for
the 50 most common zip codes in the data
and probably fewer than that depending
on how the data is distributed so this
this prevents the number of dummy
variables from blowing up now if you've
got three thousand ZIP codes in
California and you've got 50 dummy
variables there's still a lot of zip
codes you haven't encoded which are
probably in the data so in addition the
treat also converts categorical
variables to a single informative
numerical variable that takes into
account all of the pasta observed levels
and this encoding is called impact
coding and what impact coding is is
basically building a
GUP table of conditional outcomes so
going back to our zip code example you
take all the zip codes that are in the
training data you find the average home
price for that zip code and you also
find the average home price for the
entire data set so the impact value the
impact coding is the difference between
the zip code average and the global
average and that's why we call it an
impact variable so basically if you've
turned these zip codes into a numerical
value if the numerical value is negative
that means that that zip code has an
average home price that's lower than the
global average so you can kind of think
of it as that zip code has a negative
impact on home price and then if the zip
code has a positive impact variable
value then it's houses are more have a
higher sale price than average so that
zip code has a positive impact on home
price and so then you just to impact
code the zip variable you just convert
all the zip variables using this lookup
table to the appropriate value and when
you're doing this to future application
data you run into a zip code you've not
seen before
you simply encode it to 0 now the issue
with income impact coding it's very
concise and it does preserve a lot of
the data that's in the lot of the
information that's in the original data
but unlike simpler transforms like
missing value imputation and one hot end
coding impact coding to impact code a
variable you have to look at the outcome
basically an impact code is a one
variable model for the outcome in terms
of in this case zip code so if the
problem is if you use the same training
data to learn your impact code then
impact code your zip code and then use
that exact same set of training data
with this new synthetic variable to
train your downstream model you're going
to have you're going to introduce bias
because the impact code has basically
peaked at the answer so the downstream
modeling algorithm will be biased in
favor of that impact code it will look
more informative than it really is
in reality and that leads to overfit
sometimes some very bad over fit so you
want to avoid that the proper way to
impact code is to make sure that you're
learning your impact coatings on a
separate data set from what you use to
train your downstream model and the
easiest way to do that if you have
enough data and it's what I'm showing on
the diagram on the right is you take all
your training data and you split it into
two sets let's call it the calibration
set in the training set you use the
calibration set to learn this lookup
table this impact coding lookup table
with all the conditional outcomes you
throw away the calibration set you take
the other set the training set you
impact code the zip code of that set and
do all the other V treat treatments and
then you use that treated data to fit
your overall model for in this case home
price because you haven't reused the
data you will not have this nested model
problem and you will avoid that
potential / fit now if you don't have
enough data to split into calibration
and training then you have to use
cross-validation methods to create what
we call a cross frame that also will
avoid these / fit problems cross frames
aren't unique to V treat I mean
basically this cross validation method
is also the proper way to to do step
model ensembles as well they don't call
it across frames but it's the same idea
so for the purposes of this mock this
part of the talk you're gonna see the
diagram same model when I say model what
I really mean are those look-up tables
for doing the impact coding and the
model predictions are really the impact
code so the idea for the cross frame is
that no rows should be processed by an
impact coder that it wasn't included in
the construction of and I realized that
that's kind of a confusing sentence and
that's kind of a messy diagram so let's
just kind of walk through it more slowly
you have your training data and for our
interests what we're most interested in
in the data row is the zip code of the
row you partition the data into k folds
in this case three folds you take folds
two and three and you build a model or a
in code
lookup table and you use that lookup
table to encode the zip code and fold
one then you take fold one and free you
build another lookup table and use that
lookup table to in Col encode these zip
codes in fold two and then you take
folds one and two you be able to look up
table and you encode the zip codes in
fold three so now what you have is on
the far right hand side what you have is
a set of encoded zip codes for your
entire training set where every row was
encoded by a lookup table that it was
not involved in the construction of so
basically you've simulated splitting the
data into a calibration set and a
training set only you've done it in a
much more statistically efficient manner
so that you were able to use you are now
able to use all of your training data to
train your downstream model safely okay
trying to implement this
cross-validation can be a little bit of
a hassle so luckily b-tree will do it
for you
retreat' allows you to you can use V
trait either with a calibration and
training set method or with the cross
frame method if you have enough data to
split into calibration set and a
training set then you fit your V trait
train treatment plan on the calibration
set and then use that plan to transform
your training set and then that treated
data is what you use to train your
downstream model if you do not have
enough data to split into calibration
and training then you call fit underbar
transform on all of the training data
and that will simultaneously fit an
appropriate treatment plan and create a
cross frame which again will be safe to
use for training a downstream model the
important thing to note here is that
calling fit and then transform on the
same set is not the same as calling fit
underbar transform on that set that's
why I've crossed out what I'm calling
the naive call on the top if you do fit
and then transform on the same set
unless you are going to throw
the impact variables or any other way
away or treatments that's not a good
idea because you will run into just
another bias and then once you've got
your treated training set training data
and you fit a model and you want to
apply that model to new data you simply
take your existing treatment plan you
transform that new application data and
then you can play the model to it so
basically all of the V treat processes
that we've discussed in this talk are
available to you in basically one or two
lines of code easy peasy
so that's basically a quick overview of
what the most basic things that V treat
does so let's go back to the kdd 2009
example that John talked about at the
beginning of this talk and sort of see
what happens
if we try to use V treat to treat the
data and build a model with and without
the cross frames so just to point out to
you why the cross frames are important
so first we'll try treating the data
with V treat the naive way where we call
fit and then transform on all of the
training data this is the naive way
which again you're not supposed to do
you take that data the treated data and
you fit a model you try to Vout evaluate
that model that you've learned on the
training set and it looks fabulous
this model appears to have on the
training data and AUC 0.95 you're like
yay did a great model but you take this
model and then you try to apply it to
holdout data and it fails basically on
holdout data you now have an AUC 0.6 so
what you see here is that the model that
you fit without the cross frame is over
fit and does not generalize well it's a
new application data so let's try to do
it the proper way with fit underbar
transform which produces a cross frame
and use that cross frame to train your
model that produces a model that gets an
AUC 0.74 on the training data and an AC
0.73 on the test data so basically
you've managed to avoid the over fit
which is you know the goal and
you've also started with a kind of in as
John said you know ten minutes you've
got a basic model from which to start
improving to try to get better
performance so to wrap all of this up
what we've presented today is our Vitry
package which is an easy-to-use
statistically sound process to prepare
data for machine learning the prepared
data is guaranteed to be entirely
numeric and have no missing values so
it's safe to use in downstream modeling
algorithms again as John said having
automated drainage treatment is no
substitute for actually getting your
hands in the data and getting to know
what you need to understand what those
features are but what we would argue is
that the steps that we've talked about
today dealing with missing values
dealing with high cardinality variables
and novel levels guarding against novel
levels these are all kind of grungy data
steps that you have to do for basically
any machine learning problem so
basically what we do is with Vitry
you've automated the grungy common data
steps which leads you as a data science
more time for the creative steps the fun
steps for developing high domain high
value
ideas and feature engineering whatever
that are specific to your domain or your
problem and everybody wants more time
for the fun stuff which is a great idea
great reason to use Vitry references we
have on the wind vector blog we will
again we will post these slides to the
wind vector blogs and so you'll have all
these URLs we have a couple of old blog
articles on the ideas behind impact
coding so we can talk you can read about
it in more detail than i've talked about
today we also have a paper on
archive.org that discusses again all of
the ideas that we've talked about today
and probably a few more in a little bit
more detail if you're really interested
in kind of the guts of what we treat
does the via treat paper is written with
respect to the our implementation but
the ideas are the same in both implement
implementations we also have github
repositories for both with additional
documentation calling interfaces an API
etc
for the our version of treet which is
also available from cran are
downloadable from pan and the python
pandas version of a tree which is
installable from pi pi and that is my
talk our talk thank you and we will
entertain questions I noticed that a lot
of the solutions that come up make some
assumptions about the skew of the data a
lot like a lot of averaging or even lack
of meaning what's happening how do you
do you recommend before you use the tool
if you know there's potential data skew
or you just think there's data skew
based on the results not matching well
to handle it before you use the tool or
is there a good way to integrate like
implementing alternative algorithms to
do the averaging solution into something
it might like maybe you have a laplacian
or something like that so the average
doesn't really put you in the right spot
if you have you know say domain
knowledge about what the transform
should be so if for example if you
happen to already know that the
variables are say you know log normally
distributed and the mean is not
appropriate you can by default V treat
uses the mean but you know you can you
can fill in any summary statistic that's
a one variable summary statistic we
don't do a lot of sophistication so you
can use the median if that's appropriate
that mean the max whatever you happen to
calculate or a constant I would say if
you wanted to do you know say you wanted
to use Auto compute or something like
that and I've thought about this for
like a grand total of two seconds now
but I think if you wanted to use auto
impute you might be better off using
since it deals with missing values first
you'd want to do that first
I believe Auto impute does not make any
assumptions about missingness at random
versus missing this completely at random
versus missing this systematically so
you know up to you but you may want to
still additionally keep some information
about where those missing values
originally were so that you can again
hedge your bets
I saw the auto impute talk and it was
excellent by the way so
it lets the user control what they want
done whether it's missing at random or
missing systematically and yeah so the V
treat will accept as user code any one
variable imputation method however if
you want to do something smart like use
the other variables to reason about it
you would want to do that exactly as
Nina said as a pre-processing step now
again one of the V treat design
principles is nothings our fault because
we're not the last one to touch the data
the downstream model is and we gave it
that indicator variable so if wishes
were horses it would fix everything so
but again we're very sensitive that if
you want to do something intelligent
about the missing values you are joint
about the missing values you'd want to
use something as a pre-processing step
like Nina said Vee treats principle is
it treats the variables fairly
independently it says any joint property
the variables is a modeling step so it
tries to stay away from that leaving
that for you really good question though
and we've recently put in this function
thing because people are like mean is so
inappropriate for even log normal
distributions so you can type in a user
function like median and you'll be fine
hi um so I use a lot of time series data
so I really love the cross fold idea but
my issue with any cross fold is that you
end up training on past data yeah I
really want that we're doing Nina and I
are doing a lot of teaching now and for
people that have not three have not done
time series data they're like well you
just do random split and you're like no
that's not how time works that that you
know training a stock strategy that uses
Monday and Wednesdays data to trade on
the near median Tuesday that doesn't
work because it doesn't have knowledge
of the future V treat accepts as its
cross-validation arbitrary code so you
can say I want a time ordered split with
respect to all the splits yeah yeah that
simulated Python so basically in the
both the Python in the RV treat Nina's
the main scientist I'm the main coder so
when she says is that implemented it
means if I'd done what I promised her
but yeah both in R and Python the
cross-validation strategy is accept is
accepted as an external function in R an
object in Python which then you could
say this is what splits make sense to
therefore it'll work and it's also
touched on in the earlier drafts of the
paper but it was weird nobody that
didn't nobody that didn't work with
time-series understood that there's more
than random splits for cross Val it was
just frustrating trying to explain this
to people but really good president
that's it then thank you very much for
attending our talks yes and we have the
slides up on the wind vector blog so
just Google wind vector blog and it'll
have all those URLs and Nena has written
a lot of documentation for both versions
of the package so basically there's this
directory tree called examples which
shows how to get from a task to end and
then for we actually have to know what
the heck gets done to our data that's
what the more technical documents for
that there's always this problem if you
describe an implementation what's the
benefit of the implementation I just
went through all that so we've tried to
separate that and make them both
available thank you again